by now you've probably seen this video
of officer Ben fields throwing a student
to the ground in South Carolina
now the question many are asking is why
are there police officers in schools
anyway there are as many as 20,000 cops
working in schools across the country
they're called school resource officers
and what happened in South Carolina
isn't a one-off there were protests in
Rhode Island after this officer slammed
a 15 year old student to the ground the
ACLU filed a federal lawsuit after this
officer handcuffed a third grader in
2012 alone the police arrested more than
64,000 students police officers were
first introduced into the American
school system during desegregation but
towards the late 90s and especially
after the Columbine shooting in Colorado
things began to change around the
country there were calls for more police
to protect students the Justice
Department then spent seven hundred and
fifty million dollars to add 6,500 more
cops into schools this was also the dawn
of zero tolerance school policies which
were supposed to keep guns and drugs out
of schools but over time these policies
have extended to petty high school drama
like students throwing tantrums
disobeying teachers or fighting instead
of just being there for safety school
police have gotten involved in
discipline that means arrests instead of
just detention and that has
disproportionately affected black and
Latino students in fact 31 percent of
those arrested in 2012 were black
students even though they only make up
16% of the student population when 26
people were shot dead at Sandy Hook
elementary school in 2012 President
Obama allocated a hundred and
twenty-five million dollars more to add
additional police officers into schools
but experts say there's little evidence
that they improve safety what they do
know is that police in schools funnel
more minors into the criminal justice
system the so called school to Prison
Pipeline
the South Carolina officer has been
fired but maybe it's time to ask does
having cops in schools doom
more harm than good